Samsung is one of the world's largest
tech companies but it's had a low-key
presence in Silicon Valley until this
300 million dollar campus opened in 2015
[Music]
this design is about connecting people
and the design started as really two
separate buildings and then we
ultimately landed on this idea of these
two-story bars that would connect the
building on both sides and really define
this courtyard space originally this
courtyard and one of our initial and one
of our initial designs was actually
rectangular the curves weren't here it
actually it actually came together in
sort of hard edges we actually ran a
computational script and looked at what
a typical day would look like on a on an
office floor looking at how many
calories each employee might burn and
how many of their colleagues they might
see and we found was was that by
studying that if we began to round these
corners and actually create two-story
spaces behind these curved sections of
glass that improved people's visibility
and actually drew them out into those
spaces and allowed them a greater
opportunity for collaboration so how
many calories would I burn working at
Samsung every day probably just in the
course of a normal work day I have to
remember what the script said but it was
between seven and eight hundred does
this space help with productivity it
does there are a couple things that are
happening here first of all you notice
that you're getting a view and natural
light from both sides of the space
which is important there's research that
shown how natural light and views help
people focus and process information in
a more effective way than if they're in
a more closed environment so right now
we're in one of the main workspaces in
the building it's sort of an open
two-story design with the deaths all
along the outside here and then a main
staircase behind me that connects them
the architect ELLs me that the goal of
this was to sort of get people up out of
their desks moving around and then just
also to be able to see people and see
which of their colleagues are free so
they could go have a conversation have
you actually seen people connecting and
having these impromptu meetings or is
that a sort of goal that isn't playing
out in real time I think it was a goal
but I've actually seen it and I've
experienced it myself and so for example
I have lots of meetings all over the
building from any point during the day
and I'm always bumping into somebody
from another department somebody in my
organization then oh yeah oh and by the
way and you sort of find yourself having
these by the way conversations and so I
think the design of the building really
facilitates people to get up and move
around a lot and then that's where you
have those those encounters yeah I've
definitely noticed there's a lot of
walking around I feel like I've even
done a fair amount of water I think you
can get your step count up to about
10,000 without leaving the building
during the day from here you can really
get a good sense of the building design
you can see the public area down below
the first floor closed office spaces
another open-air walkway offices
open-air walkway and then the top of the
building and really what you're seeing
is the offices commitment to getting
people outside with the public area
below and the open-air floors here
no Samsung employee is more than one
floor away from being outside
we wanted people to get up out of their
desks and move and actually get out of
the building and and so rather than
having the the cafe actually inside of
the building we consciously pulled it
out across the public space so rather
than this being kind of a more of a
typical cafeteria we wanted to give it
having more of a dynamic and lighter
feel and it goes back to that whole idea
of encouraging people to come and spend
time here and potentially engage other
workers that they might not normally see
employees can choose from around a dozen
types of global cuisine prepared fresh
each day and then there's the other
perks on campus
tennis courts full court basketball a
gym a garden massage rooms a coffee shop
and the chill zone so this is the chill
zone there are foosball tables ping pong
tables arcade games sports playing on
the wall back there basically there's a
lot of not work happening in this room
it's pretty fun having this right here
in the heart of Silicon Valley allows us
to compete very well in that and that
war for talent and is it working
absolutely I think if you look at some
of the Glassdoor scores and other
metrics like that I think we've made
some some great strides in the last
couple of years in terms of having a
very very open and collaborative
environment that we've created here for
our employees do you think other
companies in Silicon Valley other tech
firms will create spaces that are more
like this I think they're gonna have to
because the younger it's a creative
that these companies are targeting that
they need basically to survive our
expecting spaces like this I think
companies will if they want to continue
to attract that talent and and stay
ahead of the curve they're gonna need to
consider you know ideas like this and in
spaces like this oh and also there are
these things called nap pods
ah not bad